et du brésil on continue d'en parler
avec philippe mouret harry les
économistes bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
alors après dix mois de négociations
houleuses un accord a enfin été conclu
entre le royaume uni et l'union
européenne et 27 pays membres viennent
d'ailleurs de donner leur feu vert on
arrive au bout de cette saga du brésis
tout est ce que quelque chose quelque
chose peut encore coincés d'ici au 1er
janvier
non je crois que rien ne peut coincer
cet accord a été long à négocier mais
maintenant les gouvernements vont vont
dire oui évidemment que le parlement
européen ne va pas prendre le risque de
voter contre cet accord lors qu'il a été
négocié par les instances européennes et
par le royaume uni donc non je pense que
l'accord au fait c'est même certain
l'accord est en place sera mise en place
provisoirement 1er janvier
définitivement dans un mois quand le
parlement européen aura voté pourquoi
est ce que le royaume uni apparaît comme
le grand gagnant de cet accord bien
parce qu en fait depuis que l'on parle
de breakbeat il y a eu beaucoup
d'intoxication par les européens qui ont
dit que c'était une catastrophe de
sortir de l'union européenne
or en fait non cet accord est fait cela
ne pose pas de problème de sortir de
l'union européenne donc les mensonges
des institutions européennes sont
démontés et ce qui fragilise sait que
lyon le royaume uni pour à commercer
librement avec l'union européenne n'y a
pas de sujet n'y a pas de catastrophe
économique et ce qui fragilise l'union
européenne c'est que cela montre que les
mauvaises politiques de l'union
européenne dont souffrent les peuples et
bien peuvent être facilement démonter
suffit de sortir de l'union européenne
et de faire un frais ximun ital exit c
c'est un précédent qui montre qu'on peut
vivre en dehors de l'union européenne
alors ben justement fait les morère
est-ce que c'est pas quelque part un
mauvais signal d'envoyer de la part de
bruxelles aux pays membres de l'ue eux
d'autres pays pourraient en effet être
tenté de quitter l'union
et puis le décrocher un aussi bel accord
que celui des britanniques
bien sûr et surtout ce qui est très
important c'est que pour tout pays
c'est une possibilité de re devenir
libres et de redevenir une démocratie le
royaume uni redevient un pays libre et a
surtout un pays démocratique
en fait ça veut dire quoi charles de
gaulle disait que la démocratie se
confond exactement que la souveraineté
nationale et c'est le cas quand les
britanniques ont voté pour boris johnson
ils ont voté notamment pour un accord
sur une très petite mais aussi pour une
hausse du smic et pour des services
publics de santé qui soit amélioré
beaucoup plus de dépenses
eh bien c'est exactement ce qu'a fait
beau et johnson quand il rentrait en
position de chef d'état il a augmenté de
6% le smic il a tenu ses promesses en
mars 2020 et il commence à augmenter les
dépenses de santé ce qu'il va continuer
à faire donc c'est une possibilité
d'être un état démocratique et que ce
que disent les chefs d'état aux
électeurs soient tenus parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous la france n'est pas
un pays libre et démocratique selon vous
pas du tout en fait comme le disait
emmanuel todd
en fait quand on a une élection
présidentielle c'est une grande scène de
théâtre où chacun promet des choses
chaque parti politique
sauf qu'en fait à la fin c'est l'union
européenne qui décide
puisqu'elle tient il y a énormément de
règles et de directives qui sont prises
ainsi on de vous promettre qu'il y aura
moins de libre échange que ce sera mieux
pour les agriculteurs français
et puis en fait on se rend compte qu'on
se retrouve toujours avec de nouveaux
accords de libre-échange récemment avec
le vietnam avec le mexique qui auront
des conséquences sur l'agriculture et
bientôt avec le brésil et donc on n'est
plus vraiment un pays démocratique très
clairement
rêvons une seconde si la france était
sortie de l'union européenne par exemple
nous ne serions pas obligé de faire de
la réforme de retraites que nous impose
l'union européenne ne serions pas obligé
de faire régresser le droit du travail
comme le demandent les grandes
politiques de l'union européenne légaux
paix ne serions pas obligé d'accepter
les accords de libre échange avec le
vietnam avec le mexique avec le brésil
donc ça change absolument tout
mon frère comment est ce que vous voyez
l'avenir du commerce et et notamment de
la pêche à présent au sein de l'union
européenne bien au niveau de la pêche
l'accord est assez négatif pour l'union
européenne puisque boris johnson a très
bien négocié lui on se retrouve en fait
avec une baisse des droits de pêche dans
les eaux britanniques qui sont les plus
poissonneuses de 25% pour l'union
européenne qui vont se faire
progressivement de pour 2 jusqu'en 2026
donc ça va être un problème pour eux
concernant les le libre échange et les
accords de commerce en général l'union
européenne va continuer à accroître la
mondialisation économique a augmenté à
signer de nouveaux accords de
libre-échange l'a récemment c'est un
accord notamment d'investissements avec
la chine qui est quand même une
dictature communiste qui est en train
d'être négocié un accord avec le brésil
qui est complètement idiot qui est en
train d'être négocié et voilà on aura
toujours plus de libre échange dans
l'union européenne
rapidement et puis ce sera le mot de la
fin federer est ce qu'on peut envisager
que l'ecosse quitte le royaume uni pour
retrouver l'union européenne non je
pense pas parce que finalement la
dirigeante écossaise avait demandé à le
faire je crois qu'il ya eu un référendum
où les écossais ont voté que non ils
veulent rester dans le royaume uni donc
je pense qu'il y aura pas de sujets là
dessus il y aura toujours des secousses
puisque il ya des indépendantistes en
écosse qui pousse le bouchon là-dessus
mais je pense que c'est pas du tout
l'intérêt des écossais de sortir du
royaume uni ils ont besoin du royaume
uni et ils vont ils rester à mon avis
philippe horaire vous êtes économiste
merci pour cet éclairage